hey guys merry here with gamespot
presents the mix at e3 2015 and I am
here with Sean baptise from adult swim
game hey thanks for having me yeah no
worries and you were here to show what
you're here to pimp again yeah on behalf
of video called video cult yeah they're
make makers of this game fine game reign
world publishing so cool it's more known
as slug cats video take a look at it
right now it's like one of the coolest
looking games visually it's absolutely
like so interesting I've never seen
anything like this unique but the
character itself is just dragging on its
front to pause there it's the best part
of a cat and the best part of a slug
mixed together they're all the best
parts there's there's no bad parts of a
cat or a slug they just morphed them
together to form this mutant feel it's
absolutely adorable and you're in this
pretty dark world Thank You crabbed I
didn't grab back in this look at you get
that if you grab a bat and then just
hold the bat will get eaten he eats it
yeah he eats the back cuz I right now
for this this demo the idea is to get 7
bats before you get and eat them before
you get back to your nest that's not the
full thing of the final game but for the
purposes of this demo that's what's
going I mean everything I've ever seen
of this game always kind of does look
like a developer demo though it still
looks like they're kind of fine-tuning
this little early on yeah there's still
a little bit early on they're adding
polish they're adding levels and more
story to it and everything right now the
Stewart right now is aur slug cat okay
done you don't need more than that yeah
you play a slug cat that's lost their
family okay and their friends and all
the other slug cats and you're trying to
go through this ancient ruin
civilization where this deadly rain is
always coming through okay um yeah
that's a real rock that you can throw
defend yourself you can throw it can you
hear that at the bath yeah not the bat
bad guy oh there are bad guys galore oh
it let he's one of them um no no no you
got you yeah all right okay we're it and
now you're dead so that's like one of
the things is it's really a survival
platformer essentially you're really
trying to make it through the there's so
much exploration that you're doing and
trying to explore these ancient ruins
while trying to get back to your family
and your friends and all of that so so
there's a there's no health bar here so
when they touch you you're dead when
it's not if they catch you if their
mouth has to sort of like grab on and
you can tell like that's one of the
things that's so awesome about this game
is the the animation style for the slug
cat I don't know if anything's been done
like this before that they have created
this sort of with slug cat he has this
procedural physics-based animation so
you're basically live controlling a rag
doll in a lot of ways that has these
animation sets and it's just it looks so
different so I'm trying to get down
there before he gets back read ibly
unique and interesting and i absolutely
love his animations they are really
different and i love it there's all
sorts of different touches that they've
put into these flood cats from where
they're climbing up a pole to where
they're on top of a pole and they're
balancing precariously it looks so we
got a terrifying bat right spider right
there they could read those things scare
the crap out of me there's like it's
it's such a cute game but it also is
legitimately terrified you this game oh
god this I am anxiously run yeah no [ __ ]
kath know this game absolutely rides the
line of cute and frightening yeah it
does that really well this look at
itself absolutely adorable really
interesting love to look at it
everything else makes me uncomfortable
and that's like probably the vibe they
were going through yeah and and the the
thing is to the world changes the way
you play it so the stronger creatures
that survived and make it they go on to
breed and create new creatures so the
world is constantly dynamically changing
based on the way you play which is also
terrifying it means sometimes you want
to get rid of the the harder thing so
that they don't have children and ruin
you later right and there's over 700
rooms in the game over 12 different
regions so there's a lot to uncover here
that they're not we're like scratching
the sir oh yeah definitely scratching
the surface oh no i don't know if i can
get out of here I
oh can you take fall damage uh naw Kham
cats die or go to save me they care if
there's nothing around all he's right
behind me run oh I don't know no dark I
can't see oh yeah you got me you got me
that's what happens you're super dead
here is game over so we could go back to
a different world as you can see even in
this demo we have a bunch of different
levels there's stuff inside of cities
there's stuff in the oceans yeah there's
somewhere new the let's go with sky
islands I remember that one being that
sounds super fun and you know each of
the regions looks very very different
and has its own visual look ya know what
is it with the ability to transport like
that so these little tube tunnels yes
slug cats are able so so the tunnels if
there are arrows oh I think I might die
if I go down here if you go through yep
I died uh so if you go hang in there
kitty so if you have a like those
tunnels that have arrows on them those
ones will just bring you to a different
place in the room so you see this one
that I will oh man that was fast slug
death Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] gets never gonna see
his family again so uh you if you see
the little arrow right there that'll
mean it'll bring me to a different place
in the room whereas if it has those
three vertical lines that brings me to a
different room so oh def again sometimes
it's some of these will go to a
different level that's a little bit less
terrifying for me let's def will go to
the suburban level but you're exploring
the other thing is I mean there's all
these different creatures and they breed
and they have different they have you
know different abilities and some are
stronger they have AI that is individual
to each creature so not even to each
species but each creature has its own
sort of personality to it and as you're
playing they get stronger and stronger
depending on how you play and it's just
it's weird how like just how much AI is
in this simple little game but it's uh I
think this is the kind of game that
appears much more simple than it
actually yeah the simplicity yeah the
simplicity kind of like belies this
incredible complexity to the world
itself we've seen
these they look like evil salamander
type enemies what else is there
eventually that we're going to be coming
there is a one of the ones that always
gets me is there's this a vulture
creature that's flying vulture creature
that will just tried to not there we go
whoo that can just descend down and just
ruin you spiders which we saw a little
bit earlier and there's a lot more
creatures that are getting worked on
right now that are really really cool
they've they've done an excellent job
just building out tons and tons of stuff
horrifying horrifying stuff and like in
this particular one is there an
objective for this particular area for
this build for this dog oh no oh no a
green one to live in every one of these
yeah it's basically to survive and
explore in the game what you're doing is
exploring these old ruins and you're
finding mysteries in them and the
mysteries that you find change the
nature of the world that you're that
you're in and because it's you know it's
always developing dynamically always
right behind me run god I am so scared
this guy I so scared yeah but yeah this
is it there's there's a lot more that's
coming that we're gonna be talking about
over the next couple of months and I'm
gonna eat this bat right no it just
gonna wait oh maybe I can if he's right
behind me you're late that's fair not
the bottom of the food at least yeah
that's a thing well that's the thing is
like at a lot of games you're the kind
of like alpha predator or you're like at
the bottom of the food chain and in this
game you're right in the middle there's
the bats below you there's the these
horrifying creatures above you there's
also one of the things of spiders that
we had that you saw before there's a
different type of spider that you can
pick up and it's just a light source so
there's levels that are completely pitch
black interesting we've seen a little
bit of that before where the enemy whose
glowing even though he's evil he was
helping light the area yeah we actually
need them yeah so you have to make
sometimes decisions about how you're
proceeding whether you want to lure one
of them into an area that's dark and I
think this is probably going to be ready
dies oh no do we for me haha well I'm
he's yeah he's trying to get me he is
dead no they will follow you for
long as they can to make sure you do it
but ya can't believe you're still alive
me neither maybe we're friends down in
some areas grabbed by the deck and
you're dead well Sean thank you so much
for showing us thank you for having when
can we expect to see rain world we are
still working on it but we will be
following L swim games on a Twitter and
we will be announcing dates very very
shortly okay well that was slug cats the
game and you can read more about that in
gamespot or check out adult swim games
and for all your other gamespot news be
sure to head to gamespot com I'll keep
saying gamespot